hello everyone my name is tony i'm from
ekf zurich and i'll be talking about
joint work with toma vidiq on
self-testing of a single quantum device
under computational assumptions
so before we get started i want to give
you some sense of where we're going in
this talk
by unpacking this title so self-testing
is a way of certifying the states and
measurements
and some untrusted quantum device
and usually this is done in a setting
where this
device is assumed to consist of two
sub-devices
and these two sub-devices are somehow
not allowed to communicate with one
another
so what's new in our work is that we get
the same
self-testing certification but for a
single quantum device so there's no more
splitting into two
non-communicating parts however to still
be able to say something meaningful we
do need a new assumption
and this is a computational assumption
so more specifically we need to assume
that the device cannot break
post quantum cryptography or more
specifically the learning with errors
problem
so i hope this gives you some sense of
where we're going but let me start with
a very basic introduction to what is
called device independence
on a very general level what we study in
device independence is this setting
we have some classical verifier down
here so let's just say that's you
you're a classical polynomial time
computer
but you've been given access to this
potentially quantum black box device
and the way you can access this device
is that you can send
classical messages to the device and you
can receive
back classical replies but you can't
actually go
and look inside to see what's going on
inside this device
so presumably you would want to use this
device to
achieve something that you can't do by
yourself so for example you might hope
that you can ask the device to please
execute
some quantum circuit and report back the
measurement results
and we call this the desired
functionality this is what you would
like the device to do ideally
but now especially in a cryptographic
setting where
you might want to use this device to
generate hopefully secure keys
you might start to wonder whether the
device really does
inside what you ask it to do or whether
perhaps it does something entirely
different that would mean that
your secure keys for example aren't
secure after all
and this is where device independence
comes in
so the idea in device independence is
that from
purely classical interaction with this
black box device
we obtain some desired output so this
might be random numbers the answer to
some computational
problem or secure keys or whatnot
but at the same time we also certify
that the device behaved as
intended so therefore we no longer need
to place any
trust in the device itself we certify
that the device
does what we hope it would do and
therefore we can also use devices that
have been prepared by a potentially
malicious
adversary so if we just
look at this setting this might seem
somewhat impossible because you know
just you
down here potentially much more powerful
black box device up here
how can you possibly constrain the
actions that this device can take
and indeed we need to make some minimal
assumption about this device
and the standard assumption that is
being made
is that this isn't one big monolithic
device but instead it consists of two
components or sub-devices
and these two components here they may
be entangled
but crucially they cannot communicate
with each other so this is why i'll call
this the non-communication assumption
you as the classical verifier still get
to classically interact with each
component individually
these two components just can't talk to
each other
so now let's see what self-testing is
in this standard setting so for
self-testing
we basically need to describe what the
protocol is that the verify
executes here and the protocol is very
simple the verify just sends
a question to each component of the
device and for concreteness
just think of this as a single bit and
then the verifier receives
some answer bit back from each component
and has some winning condition that is
evaluated
so this is just some condition applied
to these four bits here that decides
whether the device wins or loses
and this winning condition is something
that is known beforehand to everyone
so you should really think of these two
components here
as cooperating to try to win this game
with
as high probability as possible
now what is the ideal functionality what
is the desired functionality that you
would like this
device to perform in this game well this
is
that the two components should start out
with a share dpr pair
so the left component has this left
qubit here and the right component has
this right key right here
and then these inputs x and y should be
interpreted as a measurement basis
so for example zero might mean the
computational and one the hadamard basis
and these replies a and b they
ideally would be the measurement results
so what this component here gets by
measuring its
share of the epr pair in this specified
basis
and now what self-testing says is that
this desired strategy
is the unique strategy that achieves
optimum winning probability so
in other words if you have been given
access to some device of this structure
and you observe that this device wins
with
optimum or at least close to optimum
quantum
winning probability in this game then
you can conclude
that the state shared by these two
components
indeed must have been an epr pair and
that each part must have measured its
qubit in the basis requested by the
verifier
so in other words you can conclude that
the device indeed
must have executed this desired
functionality
now this is all up to
a little bit of freedom namely the
freedom of each component to choose
its local basis so
what this upper local changes of bases
means is that
you know this component here could for
example just apply some unitary or some
isometry
to both its state and its measurements
and this would leave
the classical measurement outcome that
the verifier gets to see
the same so therefore we can never hope
for the verifier
to somehow constrain the basis that each
component chooses here
and maybe just for addition when we say
a spade is
for example an epr pair up to a local
change of faces
what you should think of operationally
is that
we could have extracted an epr pair from
this state
just using local operations on each
component
so this is the standard self-testing
definition and as i said in in this talk
we're interested in
changing this setup here so in
particular we want to get rid of this
non-communication assumption
so the setting that we consider instead
is one where
we just have one big monolithic black
box
device that the verifier still only gets
to interact with
classically but we make a new assumption
this computational assumption so
specifically as i already said earlier
we assume
that this device is unable to break
post-quantum crypto
and more specifically we assume that it
is unable to break the learning with
errors problem
during the time it takes to execute the
protocol
so always denote computationally bounded
devices with these little gears
so you should be able to see the
difference
all right so now let's try to take our
self
testing definition from the standard
settings so i've just copied here what
we had
two slides ago let's try to translate
this to the single device setting
so for concreteness in the single device
setting you should just think of these
questions x and y here as being sent
together
in one go to the device and then the
verifier receiving the two answers
in one go as well as we'll see in a
minute the actual protocol is slightly
more complicated and has more rounds of
interaction
but you can just think of this for
concreteness
so let's just try to translate this we
can start the same way if the device
wins with
optimum probability or at least close to
that
then the state prepared by the device
must have been an epr pair
completely analogous to this and the
device must have measured each qubit in
the basis requested by the verifier
okay so so far this is just a one-to-one
translation
but now here we talk about local changes
of faces
and in the single device setting there's
there isn't even any notion of locality
right it's just one big monolithic
device
so instead we have to allow for global
changes of basis
but now we need to convince ourselves
this is still a meaningful
definition and the reason you might get
worried by these global changes of faces
is if you think of this extraction
intuition that i gave two slides ago
then if you just look at the state here
the statement that the state prepared by
the device must have been an epr pair
up to global changes of faces is by
itself not very interesting right
because it says we could
extract an epr pair from the state by
global operations
but of course we can just extract and
this sends an epr pair
from any state by global operations by
just tossing out the state and preparing
an epr pair
the reason why this is still a
meaningful definition is because we
aren't just certifying the state
we're certifying the state and
measurements at the same time
so in other words what we're really
certifying is how the measurements act
on this state
or what the relation between states and
measurements
is and this relation between states and
measurements
is a basis independent property so
therefore it's also something that still
makes sense
if we allow for global changes of basis
before i move on to describing a
self-testing protocol in more detail i
want to mention
some previous work so this setting with
a single computationally bounded device
and also the cryptographic
techniques that we also use in our work
were introduced
in two previous papers the first is on
certifiable information theoretic
randomness expansion by professionalism
and the second is this well-known
verification protocol for quantum
computations due to mahada
and just because this is a confusion
that comes up
um occasionally i want to briefly
clarify the difference between
verification and self-testing
what suffices to show for verification
and this is what
mahadev's protocol shows is that the
verifier can certify that there exists
a low energy eigenstate of some local
hamiltonian
so of course you could pick the epr
hamiltonian to be this local hamiltonian
so this is this hamiltonian and the low
energy eigenstate
the unique ground state of this local
hamiltonian is the epr pair
but now you're just certifying that the
epr pair exists in a mathematical sense
and and this isn't interesting right
rolling knew this all along
so what self-testing certifies is the
strongest statement that the device has
actually prepared this epr pair and then
measured it
up to this change of basis so the
difference between verification
and self-testing is that verification
just certifies existence of the state
whereas self-testing certifies that the
device is actually prepared and measure
the state
so the last piece of previous work that
i want to mention is this remote state
preparation protocol by yorkie and vidic
and this you can think of as single
qubit
self-testing so i want to explain this
in a little more detail because we can
use this as a basis for explaining how
our self-testing protocol vpr path works
so roughly how does this protocol go
we start by fixing some collection of
single keyboard states so for example
let's just pick these four states zero
and one are the computational basis
states and plus and minus are the
automatic basis states
and then the protocol has some initial
setup rounds that involve some
clever use of post-quantum crypto that
i'm not gonna explain in detail
and at this stage in the protocol here
the honest device so the device that
behaves as intended
would have prepared one of these four
qubits here or these four qubit states
so then the verifier sends over a
measurement basis
and the honest device would just take
its prepared
qubit measure it in the basis requested
by the verify
and send back the measurement result and
now the guarantee that we get from this
protocol is that if the device passes
all the checks that the verifier can
apply on
on this side then the device indeed must
have prepared one of these four states
and measured it in the requested basis
so i hope you can see why i call this a
sort of self-test
a single qubit states it certifies the
preparation and measurement
of of such a single keyboard state
now there's one additional important
property that we'll need
in a minute and this is that the
verifier knows
which one of these four states here the
device has prepared
but the device itself doesn't actually
know so this might be a bit
counterintuitive
but this is a sort of blind state
preparation where the device
can prepare the state if it behaves
honestly
but it will never find out which state
it actually has prepared
and the reason this works is again
because of how first quantum crypto
is used up here and i'm not going to
explain it in more detail
so if we want to base a self-testing
protocol
for epr pairs on this what do we need to
do
well there are two main things we need
to do firstly obviously the epr state is
a two qubit state
so now we need to go from one to two
qubits
and somehow show that the device has
prepared two qubits and
measured each of them individually and
going from one to two qubits is actually
less trivial than it might sound
because now the verifier by purely
classical interaction
somehow needs to enforce a tensor
product structure on the device's state
the second thing that we need to do is
that we don't just want to prepare a two
qubit product state but we want to
prepare an epr state
in a tangled state so the device should
entangle
its qubits with respect to the tensor
product structure that the verifier
enforced in this first step here so
this first step is in many ways the
technically
difficult one but we'll mostly take this
for granted and i'll explain how the
second step works simply because it's
quite hard to give intuition for how
this first one goes
so now let's just build a self-testing
protocol
for epr states um for this we can start
out with
two copies of this rrsp protocol and
if we were to execute these two copies
on separate
isolated devices then just by the
guarantee from the rsp protocol
we know that each of these devices here
must have prepared one of these for
single keyword states
so now let's just execute two parallel
copies
of the rsp protocol on one big device
and now what we need to show and this is
this enforcing of the tensor product
structure that i said i wasn't going to
explain in a lot of detail
we can show that this one big device
now needs to prepare these two qubits
individually so it essentially needs to
treat the two copies of the rsp protocol
separately
inside and prepare one qubit for each
copy of the protocol
this kind of has the flavor of parallel
repetition or direct product theorems
so if we take it for granted that we can
buy two parallel copies of the rsp
protocol
generate these product states here
how can we entangle them and for this
it's useful to rewrite these four by
four states
like this so this means these are the
four states 0 0
0 1 1 0 and 1 1 and and likewise down
here
and now we need to entangle them so
let's just ask the device
very kindly to execute a c not gate on
its two prepared qubits here
of course we need to certify that the
device has applied the c naught gate
correctly
but let's just consider what would
happen if we were to apply
a c not gate on these states and you can
check
just by straightforward calculation that
these first three families of states
here
they essentially remain invariant under
the c naught
so for example one zero is mapped to one
one
which is a different state but it's the
same kind of state
in contrast these two qubit product
states down here
are mapped to the four bell pairs by the
c naught gate
so the epr state would be zero zero plus
1
1 but in fact we get all four bell pairs
so why is this a useful observation it's
a useful observation
because this means that in these first
three kinds of cases here all the c
naught does
is just a re-labeling so
then if we also appropriately relabel
the checks that the verifier
did in the two copies of the rsp
protocol without a c not gate
then we can still certify single keyword
measurements
as before as when we didn't apply the c
not gate
when we didn't ask the device to apply
the c naught gate
and in this last case down here we can
now
certify bell-like correlations so this
means we can certify basically that the
parity
of these two bits here is is the
expected one
and now the last step that we need to do
is we need to somehow
combine these two statements so we need
to carry over this single qubit
measurement certification
to the bell case down here
and for this we rely on this blindness
property that i explained before
so remember that blindness basically
says that the device
cannot distinguish which of these four
cases
it is in and therefore intuitively it
also
can't change its behavior based on which
case
it is and what this allows us to do
is that we can carry over the certified
behavior in these first three kinds of
cases
down to this last case as well and in
total what that gets us is that we can
certify single keyboard measurements on
bell states
and this is the self-testing statement
that we wanted
okay so i hope this gives you some
intuition for how the protocol
goes so let me wrap up the main result
that i
showed is that we can construct a
self-testing protocol that
does away with this non-communication
assumption that
most self-testing protocols relied on
previously
and instead we can base the security
of the protocol on the device not being
able to break post quantum cryptography
and the main technique that we build on
in our work is this tight cryptographic
leash for black box quantum devices that
was introduced by berkrisk and others
so in terms of future work and if we
actually want to
implement our self-testing protocol in
practice someday
then for that we would have to improve
the robustness balance so
robustness refers to the fact that if
the device
wins with probability one minus epsilon
then how close as a function of epsilon
must the device's actual strategy be to
the ideal one or the desired one
and we do show that our protocol is
robust
in this sense it's just that the
robustness found is quite poor
numerically
secondly and perhaps more interestingly
from a theoretical point of view is
whether we can
self-test for arbitrary states in this
manner
so in our protocol we can self-test for
epr states and in fact we can self-test
for
any of the four bell pairs but of course
we would like to extend this to a larger
class of states
and i think there are two ways one could
try to go about this the first
is to take our protocol and the
techniques there and just
try to extend them to work for a larger
class of states
and the second one would be to try to
start with
mahadas certification protocol and
somehow boost
that guarantee from certifying the
existence
of ground states of local hamiltonians
to actually
certifying that the device has prepared
this ground state and then measured it
and in this latter direction there has
been some work under the
banner of quantum proofs of knowledge
but even that
seems to be a somewhat weaker statement
still than
self-testing and finally this
cryptographic leash that we've used in
our work
has potentially many more applications
so as one example of this and recently
joint work with retirement friedman
under accolade and if you do like
we were able to show that based on this
self-testing protocol we can also get a
protocol for device independent quantum
feed distribution
that similarly does away with a
non-communication assumption
and i think there are potentially many
more such applications
all right so i will stop here and thank
you very much for your attention